Liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen wir trauen um
unseren Kollegen Gero Storjohann
am 29 Januar starb er nach langer
intensivmedizinischer Behandlung
am kommenden Sonntag wäre er 65 Jahre
alt geworden
Gero Storjohann war einer erfahrener
Parlamentarier seine verbindliche und
kollegiale Art war allseits geschätzt
seit 2002 gehörte er dem Deutschen
Bundestag an er vertrat den Wahlkreis
Segeberg Stormarn Mitte
zuvor war er acht Jahre lang Mitglied
des Schleswig-Holsteinischen Landtages
Gero Storjohann wollte etwas für die
Menschen bewegen Bürger Nähe war im sehr
wichtig aus Überzeugung war er Mitglied
im Petitionsausschuss zuletzt als
dienstältester Abgeordneter
auch im Ausschuss für Verkehr und
digitale Infrastruktur hat sich Gero
Storjohann leidenschaftlich engagiert
privat war ja ein begeisterter Radfahrer
solange es seine Gesundheit zuließ vor
er fast täglich mindestens 10 km
hier im Bundestag war ja auch bekannt
als Organisator der parlamentarischen
Fahrradtour
und auch als Gründer des
parlamentarischen Kreises Fahrrad
seit seines Lebens war er ein
überzeugter Christdemokrat
schon als Schüler trat Gero stojohann in
die Junge Union ein fast 25 Jahre lang
war er Vorsitzender des
CDU-Kreisverbandes Segeberg
den Menschen in seiner Region wird er
sehr fehlen und auch uns hier im
Deutschen Bundestag
in Gedanken sind wir bei seiner Familie
und seinen Freunden ich würde Sie bitten
sich zu Ehren des verstorbenen zu
erheben
für eine Schweigeminute
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich danke
Ihnen und würde Sie bitten einen Moment
stehen zu bleiben
wir alle haben die Bilder des
furchtbaren Erdbebens in der Türkei und
Syrien vor Augen viele von ihnen haben
Betroffene im Familien- und
Bekanntenkreis und uns alle erreichen
Nachrichten aus unseren Wahlkreisen von
Menschen die sich große Sorgen machen
und mithelfen möchten das Ausmaß an Tod
Zerstörung und Leid erschüttert uns alle
zu tiefst 23 Millionen Menschen könnten
laut WHO betroffen sein
viele von ihnen sind Flüchtlinge dabei
auch viele Kinder
tausende Menschen sind bereits ums Leben
gekommen
zehntausende sind verletzt viele sind
noch immer unter den Trümmern
verschüttet und hoffen auf Rettung
frostschnee und Regen erschweren die
Rettungsarbeiten viele Überlebende
müssen die Nacht im Freien verbringen
weil ihre Häuser zerstört sind und weil
die Gefahr von Nachbeben besteht bei
eisigen Temperaturen das Erdbeben
betrifft viele Menschen die ohnehin in
großer Not leben gerade in Syrien ihre
Lage verschärft sich nun weiter umso
wichtiger ist es
das Hilfsorganisation schnell überall
Zugang zum Katastrophengebiet bekommen
die internationale Solidarität mit den
Opfern ist groß auch das Technische
Hilfswerk und andere Hilfsorganisationen
aus Deutschland haben sich auf den Weg
ins Krisengebiet gemacht
Deutschland wird selbstverständlich
weiter nach Kräften unterstützen im
Namen des ganzen Hauses danke ich von
Herzen allen die im Katastrophengebiet
unter schwierigen Bedingungen helfen und
auch allen Menschen die von Deutschland
aus zu dieser Solidarität beitragen
allen Betroffenen und ihren Angehörigen
und auch den Helferinnen und Helfern
wünschen wir alle viel Kraft und in
Gedanken auch an die Verstorbenen und
ihrer Familien bitte ich jetzt auch noch
mal kurz innezuhalten
vielen Dank bitte nehmen sie wieder
Platz
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich komme
nun
zu den Mitteilungen
zur Tagesordnung zurück
interfraktionelles vereinbart worden die
Tagesordnungspunkte um die in der
zusatzpunkte-
von der Frist für den Beginn der
Beratung soll soweit wie möglich
so weit wie erforderlich nicht wie
möglich aber erforderlich abgewichen
werden heute folgt nach der Fragestunde
auf Verlangen der Fraktion der cdu/csu
eine Aktuelle Stunde zu dem Thema Krise
auf dem Wohnungsmarkt jetzt entschlossen
gegensteuern am Donnerstag ist
vorgesehen Tagesordnungspunkt 7
abzusetzen und an dieser Stelle in
verbundener Beratung die
Tagesordnungspunkte 13 und 21 mit einer
68-minütigen debattenzeit aufzurufen
mit der gleichen debattenzeit soll daran
anschließend Tagesordnungspunkt 18
beraten werden
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 und die weiteren
Punkte der koalitionsfraktion
verschieben sich entsprechend nach
hinten wobei Tagesordnungspunkt 8 mit
einer veränderten debattenzeit von
nunmehr 39 Minuten beraten und
Tagesordnungspunkt 16 mit einer
Beratungszeit von jetzt 26 Minuten
aufgerufen werden soll außerdem soll
nach Tagesordnungspunkt achten und
Tagesordnungspunkt 23 mit einer
debattendauer von nur noch 39 Minuten
aufgerufen werden Tagesordnungspunkt 19
wird abgesetzt am Freitag ist vorgesehen
Tagesordnungspunkt 25 abzusetzen
ich mache schließlich noch auf eine
nachträgliche Überweisung im Anhang zur
zusatzpunkte-liste aufmerksam ich sehe
da sie sind einverstanden ich erkenne
keinen Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen ich rufe nun auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 1 Abgabe einer
Regierungserklärung durch den
Bundeskanzler zum außerordentlichen
Europäischen Rat am 9 Februar
2023 für die Aussprache im Anschluss an
die Regierungserklärung wurde eine Dauer
von 90 Minuten vereinbart
das Wort zur Abgabe einer
Regierungserklärung hat der
Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf Scholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
schockierende Bilder und Nachrichten
erreichen und seit Montagmorgen aus dem
Erdbebengebiet in der Türkei und Syrien
ich bin der Präsidentin sehr dankbar für
die Worte die sie eben gefunden hat und
ich denke ich spreche im Namen von uns
allen wenn ich sage wir sind erschüttert
über die vielen Toten und Verletzten
über so viel Leid und Zerstörung
unsere Gedanken sind bei den Angehörigen
die ihre Liebsten verloren haben bei den
Tausenden von Verletzten und bei denen
die vor den Trümmern ihres Hauses ihrer
Wohnung ihre Existenz stehen
die Bundesregierung hat den türkischen
Behörden unverzüglich Hilfe zugesagt das
habe ich auch in meinem Telefonat mit
Präsident Erdogan gestern bekräftigt
Suche und Rettungskräfte und technische
Experten sind vor Ort oder brechen in
diesen Stunden in die Region auf
wir die von Hilfsgüter und stehen in
engen Kontakt mit den Vereinten Nationen
um Hunde militäre humanitäre Hilfe auch
in das syrische Erdbebengebiet zu
bringen dennoch dort ist die Not
riesengroß
jetzt zeigt sich wieder einmal wie
lebenswichtig dieser
grenzüberschreitende Zugang ist für den
wir uns seit Jahren einsetzen
auch hier in Deutschland erleben wir in
diesen Tagen eine Welle des Mitgefühls
und der Hilfsbereitschaft dafür bin ich
den Bürgern und Bürgern sehr dankbar
sie zeigen auf diese Weise auch die enge
Verbundenheit unserer gesamten
Gesellschaft mit den Bürgern und Bürgern
hier in Deutschland die
Familienangehörige oder Freunde in den
betroffenen Gebieten haben
dankbar bin ich auch unseren Freunden
und Partnern in der Region nicht zuletzt
das jüngste Telefonat zwischen dem
griechischen Ministerpräsidenten und dem
türkischen Staatspräsidenten
unterstreicht doch sehr deutlich in
Katastrophen wie dieser müssen wir
zusammenrücken und uns gegenseitig
unterstützen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine
Katastrophe ganz andere Art eine
menschengemachte Katastrophe
erlebt seit fast einem Jahr die Ukraine
in wenigen Tagen jetzt sich
russlandsüberfall auf das Land
für die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine heißt
das seit zwölf quälenden langen Monaten
tagtäglich Furcht von neuen russischen
Angriffen Sorge und Trauer um die
Liebsten Angst um das eigene Leben
tausende Männer Frauen und Kinder sind
Russlands Kriegs bereits zum Opfer
gefallen
Millionen Ukraine und Ukraine sind auf
der Flucht Bomben und Zerstörung vier
Millionen haben in der Europäischen
Union Zuflucht gefunden das ist die
größte Fluchtbewegung auf unserem
Kontinent seit dem Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs
der angegriffenen Ukraine ihren tapferen
Bürgern und Bürgern gilt unser ganzes
Mitgefühl und unsere Solidarität
mit über 12 Milliarden Euro hat allein
Deutschland der Ukraine und ihren
Bürgern und Bürgern im vergangenen Jahr
zur Seite gestanden
und diese große Unterstützung setzen wir
auch in diesem Jahr fort
wir helfen beim Wiederaufbau zerstört da
Städte und Infrastruktur
stabilisieren den ukrainischen
Staatshaushalt greifen der Wirtschaft
unter die Arme leisten humanitäre Hilfe
auch bei der Lieferung von Waffen und
Munition liegen wir in kontinental
Europa weit vorne
vom ersten kriegsstand ein gilt dabei
eines der Zusammenhalt innerhalb unseres
Bündnisses und unsere Allianzen ist
unser höchstes Gut
diesen Zusammenhalt waren und stärken
wir indem wir Entscheidungen zunächst
vertraulich vorbereiten und dann erst
kommunizieren
so wie Joe beiden und ich dies zum
Beispiel mit Blick auf die jüngste
Entscheidung getan haben der Ukraine
Kampfpanzer zu liefern
was unser
Geschlossenheit hingegen schadet ist ein
öffentlicher Überbietungswettbewerb nach
dem Motto
kampfpanzerboote Flugzeuge wer fordert
mehr
was schadet sind markige innenpolitische
Statements und Kritik an Partnern und
Verbündeten auf offener Bühne
Deutschland wird sich daran nicht
beteiligen
denn jede Dissonanz jede Spekulation
über mögliche interessenunterschiede
nutzt einzig und allein Putin und seiner
Propaganda
als Bundeskanzler trage ich die
Verantwortung dafür Schaden vom
deutschen Volk abzuwenden
daraus folgen drei klare Prinzipien die
unser Handeln seit Kriegsbeginn bestimmt
wir lassen nicht zu dass ein Land sich
mit Gewalt Teiler eines anderen Landes
einverleibt und damit die
Grundprinzipien unserer Friedensordnung
in Europa in Frage stellt
deshalb unterstützen wir die Ukraine
dabei ihre Souveränität und ihre
territoriale Integrität gegen Russlands
Angriffskrieg zu verteidigen solange wie
nötig
auch die Sanktionen gegen Russland
werden wir als Europäische Union zum
Jahrestag des Kriegsbeginns noch einmal
verschärfen als klares Signal an Putin
dass er keinen Erfolg hat mit seinem
imperialistischen Plänen
zweitens wir treffen keine Entscheidung
die die NATO zur Kriegspartei werden
lassen nicht die NATO wird Krieg gegen
Russland russland hat die Ukraine
überfallen ein Großteil der
Weltgemeinschaft hat das klar verurteilt
deshalb ist es an Russland diesen Krieg
zu beenden je eher desto besser für die
Ukraine für Russland und für die ganze
Welt
putin wird seine Ziele nicht erreichen
auf dem Schlachtfeld nicht und auch
nicht durch ein diktatfrieden so viel
jedenfalls steht fest nach einem Jahr
Krieg
drittens alles was wir tun tun wir im
Gleichklang mit unseren Partnern und
Verbündeten
das war bei allen wichtigen entscheiden
so wie wir in den vergangenen zwölf
Monaten getroffen haben und dabei bleibt
es ob es um die Lieferung von
Panzerhaubitzen oder mehrfach
Raketenwerfern ging um die Ausstattung
der Ukraine mit Flugabwehrwaffen oder um
unseren Entschluss Schützenpanzer und
schließlich Kampfpanzer zu liefern vor
jedem dieser Schritte haben wir uns eng
und vertraulich abgestimmt mit den USA
mit Frankreich mit Großbritannien und
mit anderen
wir haben Logistik und Nachschub von
Anfang an mitgedacht und organisiert wir
sorgen für die Ausbildung der
ukrainischen Soldaten hier in
Deutschland koordiniert mit den
Verbündeten
und bei alledem behalten wir die Umsicht
und die Nervenstärke die es braucht um
abgewogen zu entscheiden über eine
solche Situation
darauf können die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
unseres Landes fest Vertrauen und dafür
stehe ich mit meinem Wort
den außerordentlichen Europäischen Rat
der Morgen beginnt werden wir nutzen um
unsere Positionen abzugleichen und den
weiteren Kurs abzustecken Charlie
Michelle und Ursula von der Leyen werden
uns von den Gesprächen berichten die sie
vergangene Woche in Kiew mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten geführt haben
dieser direkte Austausch mit Präsident
selenski ist uns allen sehr wichtig und
wir werden Ihnen intensiv fortsetzen
auf dem anstehenden Europäischen Rat
werden wir das Versprechen bekräftigen
dass der Europäische Rat den Ukrainern
und Ukrainern im Juni vergangenen Jahres
gegeben hat die Ukraine gehört zu Europa
ihre Zukunft liegt in der Europäischen
Union und dieses Versprechen gilt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen zur
Geschlossenheit unter Freunden und
Partnern gehört auch dass wir auf den
Feldern Vorankommen die seit Jahren
spaltpotenzial Bergen innerhalb der
Europäischen Union
eine geopolitische Europäische Union
muss diese Uneinigkeit überwinden dann
bleibt sie auch in der multipolaren Welt
des 21 jahrhunderts eine gestaltende
Kraft
ich denke dabei vor allem an die Themen
Migration und Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
über beide Themen werden wir morgen beim
Europäischen Rat intensiv beraten
gerade mal ein Jahr ist es her da hat
das Lukaschenko Regime in Belarus
Flüchtlinge für politische Zwecke
instrumentalisiert und missbraucht um
Europa unter Druck zu setzen
seitdem ist einiges vorangekommen in der
Migrationspolitik in Deutschland und in
Europa
für die Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine haben wir erstmals die
Richtlinie über den temporären Schutz
aktiviert schnell und einstimmig
das hat für Rechtssicherheit gesorgt vor
allem aber erlaubt das den ukrainischen
geflüchteten in der EU zu arbeiten und
hier in Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen
sowie
125.000 sozialversicherungspflichtig
Beschäftigte Ukraine und Ukraine die es
hier in Deutschland bereits tun
viele weitere haben zunächst
Teilzeitjobs gefunden lernen Deutsch
oder bilden sich anderweitig weiter über
eine Million Ukrainern und Ukraine sind
zu uns nach Deutschland geflogen
für unsere Städte und Gemeinden heißt
das Unterkünfte und willkommensklassen
zu organisieren Arbeitsplätze und
Hilfsangebote zu vermitteln
ich danke aber auch an
all denen die da Arbeit nicht denke an
die unzähligen Ehrenamtlichen die vielen
Vereine Initiativen oder
Religionsgemeinschaften die geflüchtete
willkommen heißen die einfach anpacken
und mithelfen
das ist ein Zeichen großer
Menschlichkeit und dafür sage ich von
ganzem Herzen Danke und noch etwas will
ich hinzufügen wir lassen Sie nicht
allein
begrüße ganz ausdrücklich dass die
bundesinnenministerin alle
Verantwortlichen im Bund in den Ländern
und Kommunen schon bald zu einem
erneuten Spitzengespräch über die
anstehenden Herausforderungen
zusammenbringt
der Bund hat die Länder und Gemeinden
bei der Registrierung der Flüchtlinge
unterstützt und wie schon im Vorjahr
greift der Bund den Ländern und
Gemeinden auch in diesem Jahr mit
Milliarden unter die Arme um die
ankommenden gut zu versorgen
auch in anderen Ländern Europas ist die
Hilfsbereitschaft groß in diesen Geist
der Gemeinsamkeit werden wir beim
Europäischen Rat morgen auch die
Herausforderung themaisieren die über
die Unterstützung ukrainischer
Flüchtlinge deutlich hinausgehen
mit vielen meiner Kolleginnen und
Kollegen habe ich im Vorfeld intensive
Gespräche geführt nach Jahren des
Stillstands ist Fortschritt möglich in
der europäischen Asylpolitik
das ist auch ein Verdienst der
französischen der tschechischen und der
gegenwärtigen schwedischen
Ratspräsidentschaft mit der Einigung des
Rats auf die euro-dack und die
swinging-verordnung haben wir jahrelange
Blockaden aufgelöst und ich werbe dafür
dass wir die Verhandlung darüber mit dem
Europäischen Parlament nun mit Hochdruck
vorantreiben denn wir brauchen Klarheit
wer nach Europa kommt und warum
das ist das A und O jeder erfolgreichen
Reform unseres Asylsystems
das zweite Element ist eine wirksame
Kontrolle unserer Außengrenzen auch mit
Hilfe von Frontex
Ursula von der Leyen hat dazu im Vorfeld
des morgigen Rates wichtige Vorschläge
gemacht zum Beispiel bessere gemeinsame
grenzpatroien mit unseren Nachbarstaaten
außerhalb der EU
und es war richtig dass wir dafür
gesorgt haben dass die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen der EU und der Türkei im
flüchtlingsbereich fortgesetzt wird
last but not least brauchen wir auch die
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten an der
EU-Außengrenze selber
die noch unsere Unterstützung haben
müssen materiell finanziell aber eben
auch dadurch dass andere Staaten
freiwillig Asylsuchende übernehmen
und auch hier gehen wir mit dem
freiwilligen solidaritätsmechanismus in
der EU neue Wege indem wir die
Verantwortung der Außengrenzen Staaten
für die Kontrolle und Registrierung von
Asylsuchenden verknüpfen mit der
Solidarität der anderen
auch das kommt voran
und deshalb bin ich zuversichtlich dass
seine Reform des europäischen
Asylsystems noch in der laufenden
europäischen Legislaturperiode möglich
ist wenn wir das Tempo und den
Pragmatismus der vergangenen 12 Monate
beibehalten
dabei kann auch ein Aspekt eine Rolle
spielen der in der Vergangenheit oft
vernachlässigt wurde
immer mehr Länder in Europa sind da auf
Arbeitskräfte Zuwanderung angewiesen
gesteuert human und im Einklang mit dem
Recht
das gilt auch für Deutschland wir
brauchen Fachkräfte in großer Zahl
natürlich investieren wir zunächst in
die Ausbildung und Qualifizierung der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer die
hier sind wir möglichen Eltern
erwerbstätig zu sein indem wir für
bessere ganztags Kinderbetreuung und
Ganztag Schulen sorgen und wir erweitern
die Hinzuverdienstmöglichkeiten zum
Beispiel für früh und
Erwerbsminderungsrentner
aber wer auf die Zahl all derjenigen
schaut die in den kommenden Jahren in
Rente gehen der versteht nur mit diesen
Maßnahmen wird sich der Fachkräftemangel
nicht beheben lassen der sich über Jahre
hinweg in Deutschland aufbaut
in den vergangenen Jahren sind viele
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer aus
anderen EU-Mitgliedsstaaten zum Arbeiten
nach Deutschland gekommen der
Freizügigkeit innerhalb der Europäischen
Union seit danke
doch auch dieses Potenzial ist nicht
endlos
und darum braucht unser Land
qualifizierte Frauen und Männer auch von
außerhalb Europas die in unseren
Unternehmen in unseren Krankenhäusern in
der Pflege und in unseren
Handwerksbetrieben mit anpacken
gut also das wäre in Deutschland in den
nächsten Monaten nun endlich einen
modernes Zuwanderungsrecht schaffen dass
solche Talente hierher nach Deutschland
eingelegt
und zugleich und zugleich ist ganz klar
wer hier kein Bleiberecht erhält der
muss Deutschland auch wieder verlassen
deshalb haben wir die rechtlichen Hürden
gesenkt Straftäter und Gefährder
auszuweisen und die Abschiebehaft
verlängert
deshalb haben wir dafür gesorgt dass
Asylverfahren schneller gehen und wir
früher wissen wer hier bleiben darf und
wer nicht auch die asylverfahrenen
unseren Verwaltungsgerichten verkürzen
und vereinheitlichen wir damit es
schnellere und eindeutige Entscheidungen
gibt wir haben die
binnenkonferenzkontrollen dann der
Grenze zu Österreich verlängert führen
Schleierfahndung an der
deutsch-tschechischen Grenze durch und
gemeinsame Kontrollen mit der Schweiz
und nicht zuletzt werden wir legale
Möglichkeiten der Migration noch
konsequenter verknüpfen mit der klaren
Erwartung gegenüber den Herkunftsländern
ihre Staatsangehörigen zurückzunehmen
wenn diese hier kein Bleiberecht haben
letztes Jahr haben wir ein solches
migrationsabkommen mit Indien
abgeschlossen das funktioniert schon
sehr erfolgreich
und weitere dieser Abkommen werden
folgen um sie abzustimmen haben wir mit
Joachim stammt gerade ein
sonderbevollmächtigten für
migrationsabkommen eingesetzt und
parallel dazu wollen wir auch in der EU
solche migrationspartnerschaften
voranbringen auch dazu hat Ursula von
der Leyen Vorschläge gemacht und dafür
hat sie unsere volle Unterstützung
so bringen wir Ordnung in das System und
so setzen wir die richtigen Anreize und
was vielleicht am wichtigsten ist so
erhalten wir die Akzeptanz die ist in
unserem Land sowohl für die
Freizügigkeit innerhalb der EU als auch
für eine klug gesteuerte Zuwanderung von
Fachkräften gibt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
zweite große Thema dass wir uns beim
Europäischen Rat vornehmen ist die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit Europas auch hierzu
hat die Kommission vernünftige
Vorschläge gemacht auf dieser Grundlage
werden wir nun miteinander beraten wie
wir unseren Unternehmen den Wandel zur
Klimaneutralität erleichtern erst recht
in diesen für viele Unternehmen
fordernden Zeiten
und zugleich stimmig nicht ein in den
Cord derjenigen die seit Monaten mit
düsteren Prophezeiung wahlweise eine
tiefere Session die die
Industrialisierung Europas oder die
Abwanderung von Zukunftstechnologien an
die Wand malen keines dieser
negativszenarien ist bislang eingetreten
und sie werden auch nicht eintreten weil
Deutschland und Europa die Segel richtig
setzen in Sachen Energiesicherheit und
Energiewende in Sachen
Zukunftstechnologien und Rohstoff
Verfügbarkeit in Sachen
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
Innovationsförderung
die Großhandelspreise für Energie liegen
dank neuer Terminals neuer Lieferanten
europäischer Solidarität und kluger
Entlastungsmaßnahmen inzwischen wieder
auf dem Niveau von vor dem Kriegsbeginn
zum Teil sogar darunter
die Inflationen in Europa sinkt die
Industrieproduktion ist stabil das
Wirtschaftswachstum in der Europäischen
Union ist im letzten Quartal nicht
geschrumpft sondern sogar leicht
gestiegen im Gesamtjahr 22 lag es höher
als das Wachstum in China oder den USA
die Zahl der Beschäftigten in
Deutschland und in der Europäischen
Union nicht auf Rekord hoch
und auch bei der Diversifizierung
unserer Lieferketten und Absatzmärkte
kommen wir voran
erst vergangene Woche war ich mit einer
großen Wirtschaftsdelegation in
Südamerika unterwegs Ergebnis dieser
Reise sind neue Energie Rohstoff und
unternehmenspartnerschaften neue
Mitglieder in dem von uns ins Leben
gerufenen klimaklub und zugleich das
klare Signal das eu-freihandelsabkommen
mit dem Markus Suren und endlich unter
Dach und Fach zu bringen
meine Damen und Herren zuletzt haben die
USA mit ihrem Inflation reduction Act
die Diskussion um eine aktive Industrie
und Standortpolitik für
Zukunftstechnologien Neuanfang
so richtig es ist dass wir uns mit den
Folgen dieser Politik für Europa
beschäftigen
Cassandra rufe sind auch hier nicht
angezeigt
zum einen es ist doch begrüßenswert dass
die USA den Wandel hin zur
Klimaneutralität jetzt endlich ähnlich
entschlossen angehen wie wir
und zum anderen besitzen wir in Europa
durchaus die wirtschaftlichen
Voraussetzungen und die
Förderinstrumente um den klimaneutralen
Wandel der Industrie zu meistern
das hat die Kommission selber
vorgerechnet
allein die aufbaupassilität die wir
während der corona-pandemie geschaffen
haben
hat einen Umfang von 250 Milliarden für
die dekarbonisierung der europäischen
Industrie nur ein geringer Teil davon
ist bislang ausgegeben aus der
Initiative Repower EU können wir bald
weitere 20 Milliarden an Zuschüssen und
ein dreistelligen Milliardenbetrag an
Krediten einsetzen
mit dem invest-eu-programm fördern wir
öffentliche und private Investitionen in
Zukunftstechnologien unterlegt mit einer
Garantie des EU-Haushaltes in Höhe von
26 Milliarden Euro
hinzu kommen rund 40 Milliarden für
Forschung und Innovationen die den Green
Deal unterstützen davon profitieren in
erster Linie europäische
Forschungseinrichtung und schließlich
stehen aus dem Kohäsionsfonds und aus
dem europäischen Emissionshandel
beträchtliche Mittel zur Verfügung
wenn man all das neben die
Förderprogramme aus den USA im Umfang
von 370 Milliarden Dollar legt dann
sieht man europa braucht sich nicht zu
verstecken
wir werden uns also sehr genau anschauen
ob und wo unsere Programme noch Lücken
lassen und wie man diese dann schließen
kann dafür braucht es aber zunächst eine
sorgfältige Analyse wie sie die
Kommission in Aussicht gestellt hat ein
ungehemmter subventions-bettlauf mit den
USA wäre aber mit Sicherheit der falsche
Weg
in den vergangenen Wochen habe ich mit
vielen Unternehmen gesprochen in Davos
und bei meinen Besuchern in
Rheinland-Pfalz Hessen und im Saarland
dort im Saarland in Ensdorf haben ein
deutsches und amerikanisches Unternehmen
gerade den Startschuss gegeben für eines
der größten Werke weltweit für
Halbleiter aus Siliziumcarbid Halbleiter
die wir für den Ausbau erneuerbare
Energien für Elektromobilität und
Kommunikationstechnologien unbedingt
brauchen
diese Investition ist nur eine von
mehreren internationalen
Großinvestitionen in die
Halbleiterindustrie in Deutschland und
in Europa auch in Sachsen und in
Sachsen-Anhalt zum Beispiel stehen
Unternehmen in den Startlöchern
und die Frage der Investoren lautet
nicht nur und zuallererst wo ist der
nächste große Fördertopf
ihr Anliegen ist dass wir das bestehende
Beihilferecht vereinfachen das
Förderentscheidung schneller und
berechenbarer getroffen werden dass wir
vorhandene Finanzinstrumente flexibel
nutzen genau das schlägt die Kommission
in ihrer Mitteilung für den anstehenden
Europäischen Rat vor und dafür bin ich
hier sehr dankbar
um Europa im weltweiten Wettbewerb zu
stärken müssen wir erstens Ernst machen
mit dieser angekündigten
Flexibilisierung des europäischen
beihilferechts und zwar gezielt in den
Sektoren die wir für die Transformation
brauchen und wir werden zweitens unsere
europäischen Produktionskapazitäten für
fortschrittliche saubere Technologien
ausweiten etwa im Energiebau und
Verkehrsbereich nur so werden wir die
absehbar stark steigende Nachfrage
danach bedienen können
darum hat sich die Bundesregierung schon
im vergangenen Herbst für eine
cleantech-initiative eingesetzt mit der
solche transformationstechnologien
befristet gefördert werden können und es
ist gut dass die Kommission diese Idee
zwischen zu einem ihrer zentralen Ziele
erklärt hat
und wir setzen drittens weiter auf
freien und Fähren handeln
denn unter dem Bedingungen einer
deglobalisierung kann die weltweit
nötige Transformation hin zur
Klimaneutralität nicht gelingen
dafür braucht es fairen Wettbewerb
Innovationen offene Märkte und globalen
Handel der hohe Sozial- und
Umweltstandards voranbringt
das Freihandelsabkommen mit dem Markus
zur Staaten habe ich bereits erwähnt
darüber hinaus ist es mir ein großes
Anliegen dass den wegweisenden Abkommen
mit Kanada Korea Japan Vietnam und
Singapur bald weitere ambitionierte
moderne Freihandelsabkommen folgen
deshalb wollen die ausverhandelten
Abkommen mit Neuseeland und Chile nun
zügig in Kraft-
unsere laufenden Gespräche über den im
Flächen reduction Act sind dafür eine
gute Ausgangsbasis jedenfalls dann wenn
die USA auf Regeln verzichten die
europäische Unternehmen zum Beispiel
gegenüber Unternehmen aus Kanada oder
Mexiko benachteiligen
darüber beraten wir mit unseren
amerikanischen Freunden
partnerschaftlich gelassen und
vertrauensvoll
damit schließt sich der Kreis zu dem was
sich eingangs darüber gesagt habe wie
wir uns mit unseren Partnern abstimmen
die Erfahrung der vergangenen zwölf
Monate zeigt nicht die schnelle laute
Forderung setzt sich durch sondern sie
durchdachte ordentlich abgestimmte und
daher tragfähige Idee
daraufhin zu wirken darin liegt für mich
übrigens auch Deutschlands Rolle in
Europa
dabei geht es ums führen durch
zusammenführen indem wir nämlich
Lösungen zusammen mit anderen erarbeiten
das ist und bleibt der Kompass dieser
Bundesregierung in der außen und
Europapolitik und dieser Kompass
begleitet mich auch morgen zum
Europäischen Rat nach Brüssel vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank ich eröffne die Aussprache
und zuerst hat das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Friedrich Merz
frau Präsidentin lassen Sie mich
zunächst namens der